PROFESSOR: Hey, Kenneth.
KENNETH CHEAH: Hi.
PROFESSOR: So how do you
feel with it being over?
KENNETH CHEAH: A little nervous
because I'm having my friends
from Singapore come over.
Some of them will be
seeing it, and I'm not sure
how they really would
like it or not like it.
So yeah, I'm a little nervous.
PROFESSOR: How was this
class different from the ones
that you've taken at SUTD?
KENNETH CHEAH: I think it's a
lot more hands-on, definitely.
We have a similar
course back in SUTD,
where it's called
Film Studies, but I
think that's a more
film-related module.
This feels a lot more like
a good mix between education
and entertainment.
It's really, really nice
to see all this stuff
that you always wanted to
do or you always see around.
I see so many people
making YouTube videos
and you're kind of learning
the theory behind it all.
And usually, it was just, oh,
let's just set up a camera
and just put it on,
but there is actually
a lot more going into it.
And yeah, probably that's what's
the difference between all
the good videos you see and
some people just teaching
how to derive some equations
on a blackboard, I guess.
PROFESSOR: What is
the most useful thing
that you learned in the class?
KENNETH CHEAH: I think the
small class size really, really
helps and the fact that
we just help each other.
We give each other feedback.
The conventional way would
just be turn in your ideas
and one teacher or maybe two
teachers would just grade it.
But this, you get the
whole class's feedback,
which is a lot more useful.
PROFESSOR: Do you think
it would work if it
were more than ten people.
KENNETH CHEAH: I think it might
be a bit hard because things
and people may
not be to gel that
well to be able to be
comfortable to give
too much comments.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Thank you very much.
KENNETH CHEAH: Thank you.